le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
nos animaux d'élevage sont ils bien
portants les produits alimentaires que
nous importons sont-ils st l'hygiène
alimentaire dans les cantines scolaires
est elle respectée depuis plus de 40 ans
le laboratoire vétérinaire départemental
surveille de près notre chaîne
alimentaire
l'établissement nous a ouvert ses portes
pour nous faire découvrir ses missions
[Musique]
ce n'est pas florent qui transigera avec
l'hygiène ce matin ce technicien en
laboratoire vétérinaire est venu
chercher de la nourriture dans cette
cantine scolaire
pas pour la manger mais pour l'analyser
je vais faire un prélèvement sur la
vitrine du sahel fait froid sur les
assiettes ainsi que sur la table du
réfectoire aliments équipements
vaisselle tout y passe florent travail
pour le laboratoire vétérinaire
départemental son rôle surveiller la
qualité de la restauration collective
le but en fait de faire des prélèvements
alimentaires au niveau de ces
différentes restaurations de ramener des
échantillons alimentaires au niveau des
terres
ensuite au niveau du conseil
départemental
on a environ soixante dix sept collèges
ont fait bien à peu près 55 collège
ensuite on fait aussi pas mal de
communes la restauration de pas mal de
communes et de lycées on analyse des
échantillons venant de pme/pmi des
abattoirs un peu de tout quoi le
technicien intervient une fois par mois
dans ce collège de saint denis
pas de quoi inquiéter le personnel ici
chacun respecte les règles d'hygiène
hall à l'échalote est habillé jetable et
plastique les gants et âgées si on fait
ce qu'il faut veiller à faire il ya
passé par 7 septembre entre nous on voit
si un souci à participer voilà est-ce
que je peux récupérer là dedans dans
l'armoire choc
une fois son butin bien à l'abri dans la
glacière flore on regagne aussitôt le
laboratoire une fois rentrée c'est au
tour du scientifique de faire sa petite
cuisine
maintenant je vais mettre l'appareil va
aspirer le diluant tu es là bas la
mixture est ensuite soigneusement broyer
enfin le but c'est de mettre en
suspension tout légère qui sont au
fabuleux de l'aliment de façon pouvoir
les récupérer ensuite et les mettre en
culture
ce que recherche florent c'est la
présence éventuelle de bactéries telles
que la listéria ou la salmonelle mais le
rôle du laboratoire ne s'arrête pas là
les équipes travaillent aussi avec les
agriculteurs
donc les suisses une salle en fait tout
vous savez ya un règlement
les clés les ports les ports qui sont
abattues dans toute l'union européenne
david est contrôlée contre le risque de
parasites ont les maladies n'existe pas
la réunion mais les contrôles sont quand
même obligatoire pour que la france
conserve 11
pour répondre à ces normes européennes
les scientifiques sont susceptibles
d'intervenir à chaque étape de la
production
c'est une chaîne qu'il faut assainir à
tous les niveaux donc les matières
premières qui arrivent au port
son statut d'acteur analyser les
éléments qui sortent de l'usiné sont
susceptibles d'être analysé les animaux
comme l'environnement d'élevage et après
le laboratoire a été créée en 1962 au
départ il s'occupait surtout des
maladies bovines et porcines
aujourd'hui l'établissement a élargi son
domaine de compétence et son travail est
accrédité par le cofrac
le comité français d'accréditation nous
avons soutenu le laboratoire de la
réunion dans sa recherche
d'accréditation cofrac pour permettre de
garantir je dirais à l'analyse technique
effectuée par ce laboratoire
il faut savoir que 75% des analyses sont
pour le monde agricole 25% pour
l'hygiène alimentaire il était important
que ces résultats soient certifiés de
cette accréditation cofrac dans le
laboratoire
florent vient de terminer ses
préparations tuer mais c'est pour toi
après tu aimes est à l'étude les
échantillons sont prêts à être testées
jusqu'à maintenant
90% des résultats du laboratoire se sont
révélés conformes aux normes européennes
de quoi savourer son shop suis poisson
en toute tranquillité
[Musique]
le laboratoire vétérinaire départemental
a été créée en 1962 ces missions
concernent principalement la santé
animale et l'hygiène alimentaire en 2017
le laboratoire vétérinaire départemental
a obtenu une accréditation du cofrac
pour la recherche de salmonelle le tri
chine et de sérologie brucellose 90% des
résultats obtenus sont conformes aux
normes européennes
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
consulter le site du département ou
www.cc marseille 4 point fr
[Musique]